[Música]
la rusa gazprom anunció que reducirá la
cantidad de gas natural que suministra a
europa a través del norte swing 1 el
gasoducto transportará únicamente el 20
por ciento de su capacidad lo que
profundiza la crisis energética del
bloque de los 27 tenemos reportes desde
moscú y berlín
por primera vez en tres décadas en mi
amar le aplicaron la pena de muerte a
prisioneros cuatro activistas
prodemocracia fueron ejecutados a
principios de este año los condenaron en
un juicio a puerta cerrada y fueron
sentenciados por colaborar con actos de
terroristas
el hecho fue condenado por naciones
unidas eeuu y amnistía internacional
túnez vota hoy su referendo sobre una
nueva constitución que propone el
presidente que easyjet el texto
reduciría los poderes del parlamento y
los concentraría en la figura del
mandatario la oposición teme que de ser
aprobada la carta magna- acabe con los
logros alcanzados tras la primavera
árabe y ponga de vuelta al país en el
camino a la autocracia
bienvenidos a la actualidad
internacional en france 24 yo soy maría
clara calle gracias por estar con
nosotros
iniciamos con noticias de europa la
estatal rusa gazprom reducirá todavía
más el suministro que provee a la unión
europea a través de nuestro in 1 a
partir del miércoles este gasoducto
operará únicamente al 20% de su
capacidad gazprom argumenta que la
reducción fue porque apagaron una
segunda turbina por reparaciones aunque
el ministerio de economía alemán
sostiene que no hay razones técnicas
para la disminución esta reducción de
los envíos ha sido progresiva a mediados
de junio gazprom comenzó a suministrar
sólo el 60 por ciento de la capacidad de
north swing y desde esta semana las
entregas estaban al 40 por ciento desde
rusia nuestro corresponsal xavier colás
nos amplía
russia anunciado que va a restringir
todavía más el flujo de gas que
suministra a alemania la principal
economía de europa
alemania recibirá sólo una quinta parte
del flujo habitual y recordemos que el
país está allá bajo mínimos puesto que
ahora mismo está recibiendo sólo el 40
por ciento de lo que normalmente recibía
por parte de gazprom la razón que
esgrime moscú es que hay de nuevo
problemas con una de las turbinas
recordemos que había estado preparándose
en canadá pero desde la unión europea se
ha acusado a rusia y en varias ocasiones
de estar utilizando el chantaje
energético en todo caso la noticia llega
en un momento muy complicado para los
países europeos para todos ellos puesto
que puesto que precisamente ahora es
cuando se están dedicando a llenar sus
depósitos de gas subterráneos de cara al
invierno y desde berlín nuestro
corresponsal todo más sparrow nos
explicó las preocupaciones el anuncio de
gazprom despierta en alemania en una
primera reacción del gobierno alemán a
el ministerio de economía explicó que
estaba monitoreando muy de cerca la
situación y explicó que no considera que
haya razones técnicas que expliquen el
recorte en el suministro con esto las
autoridades alemanas sugieren más bien
que detrás de los recortes de suministro
puede haber una razón política de parte
de moscú de cualquier manera este es un
tema muy importante que genera también
preocupación en alemania si bien
alemania ha reducido su dependencia
energética con rusia desde que comenzó
la guerra en ucrania aún importa
alrededor de un tercio de su gas de
rusia lo que la hace particularmente
vulnerable y buena parte de esa
importación ocurre precisamente a través
del gasoducto nord stream 1 las
autoridades ya pusieron en marcha
para garantizar la seguridad energética
que incluye aumentar el almacenamiento
de gas de cara a los meses de invierno
diversificar las fuentes energéticas no
solamente con energías renovables sino
también con el uso de carbón para
generar energía y también se les ha
pedido tanto a las industrias como a los
ciudadanos que ahorren energía en la
mayor cantidad posible en más
información relacionada con la guerra en
ucrania el kremlin aseguró que su ataque
con misiles ocurrido el sábado 23 de
julio contra el puerto de odessa en el
mar negro no puede ni debe afectar el
acuerdo para exportar granos ucranianos
el pacto lo lograron en estambul justo
un día antes del bombardeo el portavoz
de la presidencia rusa dmitri peskov
afirmó que esa acción tuvo que ver
exclusivamente con infraestructura
militar y de ninguna manera estuvo
relacionada con la infraestructura que
se emplea para el cumplimiento del
acuerdo para la salida de los cereales
entretanto altos funcionarios del
gobierno ucraniano aseguraron este lunes
que esperaban que el primer envío de
grano
esta misma semana y que las
exportaciones siguen realizándose desde
todos los puertos acordados en un plazo
de dos semanas el ministro de
infraestructura de ucrania también
aseguró que no hay límites para la
cantidad de grano que pueda exportarse
desde territorio ucraniano escuchemos
las declaraciones de ambas partes
mira los bombardeos están conectados
exclusivamente con la infraestructura
militar de ninguna manera están
relacionados con la infraestructura que
se utilizará para cumplir con el acuerdo
de exportación de granos entonces esto
de ninguna manera puede afectar ni
afectará el inicio de envíos
esperamos que el primer envío de granos
se complete esta semana el puerto de
chornomorets será el primero luego el de
odessa en general en dos semanas
estaremos técnicamente preparados para
exportar desde todas las terminales de
los puertos mencionados nales nuestras
marchas drop work if a propósito de la
exportación de cereales el canciller
ruso sérguei lávrov continúa su gira por
áfrica en un intento por tranquilizar a
sus aliados árabes sobre el suministro
de alimen lávrov llegó este lunes al
congo luego de visitar egipto en el
cairo afirmó que rusia está decidida a
ayudar a los ucranianos a librarse de la
carga de un régimen que tildó de
absolutamente inaceptable estas
declaraciones contrastan con las que
emitió el kremlin al principio de la
guerra en las que aseguraba que no
buscaba derrocar al gobierno de
volodymyr se le esquivamos el informe en
el marco de una preocupante crisis
alimentaria rusia busca fortalecer sus
vínculos diplomáticos en áfrica de
visita en el cairo el ministro de
exteriores ruso serguéi lávrov quiso
tranquilizar a sus aliados árabes que
dependen de los cereales y de las armas
exportadas desde moscú exportaciones
alteradas por la guerra en ucrania
hemos confirmado el compromiso de los
exportadores de cereales rusos a
respetar todas sus obligaciones
nuestros colegas occidentales que se
toman muy en serio la situación actual
tienen que levantar los obstáculos que
ellos mismos han creado
desde el inicio de la invasión rusa de
ucrania la inseguridad alimentaria
aumenta en áfrica que importa en su
conjunto el 40 por ciento del stock de
trigo de los dos países en guerra la
situación se agrava en egipto primer
importador mundial de trigo que compra
un 80 por ciento del trigo que consume a
moscú ya kiev
egipto estado claramente afectado por
esta crisis en términos de seguridad
alimentaria energética de inflación que
afecta la economía internacional y la
suspensión de las cadenas de suministro
son algunas de las cosas en las que
tenemos que trabajar
tras su paso por egipto serguéi lávrov
ya se encuentra en el congo y
posteriormente visitar a uganda y
etiopía encuentros en un momento
oportuno tras el acuerdo alcanzado el
viernes entre moscú y kiev para poder
exportar las más de 20 millones de
toneladas de cereales bloqueadas en los
puertos ucranianos del mar negro y
reducir así el riesgo de una crisis
alimentaria mundial sin embargo el
ataque ruso con misiles al puerto de
odessa este sábado arrojó dudas sobre la
viabilidad del pacto
y la guerra de nuclear ya entra en su
sexto mes una de las novedades del
conflicto es que el gobierno ucraniano
empezó una contraofensiva para recuperar
el control de gerson esta fue la primera
región que los rusos controlaron ellos
gobiernan allí desde marzo y ahora aquí
es intentar revertir el poder usando los
misiles de alta precisión que le ha dado
occidente especialmente de eeuu les
contamos más en este reporte
fue la primera ciudad importante en caer
ante las fuerzas rusas y ahora ucrania
dice que se ha alcanzado un punto de
inflexión en la región de gerzón durante
el fin de semana el presidente ucraniano
dijo que sus tropas estaban avanzando
paso a paso hacia la ciudad un
sentimiento que llegó a los soldados en
terreno
liberaremos gerson esto es seguro no lo
entregaremos a los rusos por eso estamos
aquí para que nuestros hijos no tengan
que luchar más para que podamos resolver
este asunto ahora y para siempre me voy
a volver con
estos soldados ucranianos están luchando
para retomar gerson y aunque por ahora
son capaces de mantener sus posiciones
son conscientes de que necesitarán más
armas antes de lanzar cualquier
contraofensiva
muy bien y j
realmente no tenemos suficiente
artillería aquí si le disparamos ocho
veces nos devuelve en el fuego 48 veces
por ahora tienen superioridad en
artillería justo en las últimas semanas
las tropas ucranianas han ido
recuperando poco a poco territorio en
gerzón con la ayuda de armas
occidentales ucrania afirma haber
atacado depósitos de armas rusos en los
alrededores de la ciudad y haber
destruido tres puentes clave aunque
rusia niega que se vaya a producir una
contraofensiva los servicios de
inteligencia occidentales muestran que
las posiciones defensivas de moscú se
están reforzando
ahora vamos hasta mianmar donde la junta
militar en el poder
ejecutó a cuatro activistas
prodemocracia entre los prisioneros se
encuentra un legislador del partido
político de la ex líder democráticamente
elegida a un samsung y así como una
figura destacada del movimiento
prodemocrático del país de finales de la
década de 1980 estas son las primeras en
mianmar desde hace décadas el mundo las
condena damos el informe de juan pablo
lo cubre
indignación internacional las
ejecuciones a cuatro activistas
prodemocracia que anunció la junta
gobernante de mianmar este lunes trajo
un rápido rechazo de organizaciones
internacionales de derechos humanos
periodistas y de naciones unidas- los
condenados a muerte tras varios juicios
a puerta cerrada fueron acusados a
ayudar a insurgentes a luchar contra el
ejército que tomó el poder en febrero de
2021 en intentos fallidos la comunidad
internacional ha hecho varios llamados
para que la junta militar ponga fin a
los procesos contra activistas y se teme
que más opositores estén en la lista de
espera para ser ejecutados calculamos
que puede haber al menos 140 personas
que están en el corredor de la muerte
los militares tienen planeado seguir
llevando a cabo ejecuciones mientras
siguen bombardeando pueblos y deteniendo
a personas inocentes en todo el país
sutiss a las autoridades militares a
través de esta especie de tribunales
inventados en donde han acortado los
procedimientos que no tienen
prácticamente ningún derecho de
apelación ningún derecho de clemencia
hemos visto que esencialmente el uso de
la pena de muerte se ha convertido en
una parte integral de la retención del
poder seguir reprimiendo la oposición
el gobierno japonés ha condenado a las
ejecuciones las primeras en tres décadas
y la vecina china aunque ha puesto por
delante el principio de no injerencia ha
dicho que el país debe resolver sus
diferencias y conflictos rápidamente
pero los birmanos piden menos diplomacia
y más acciones concretas la respuesta de
la comunidad internacional sólo son
palabras ya sabes cómo vamos a hacer
esto nos preocupamos hicimos aquello
blah blah blah ya sabes no hay nada en
acción si hubiera algo en acción este
tipo de ejecuciones no ocurrirían ni al
mar está sumido en un caos desde el
golpe de estado del año pasado en donde
se calcula que más de dos mil
manifestantes murieron luego de que las
fuerzas de seguridad utilizarán munición
real en contra de los civiles
92 millones de votantes están llamados a
las urnas hoy en túnez para el referendo
con el que se elige si instaurar o no
una nueva constitución el 12% del padrón
electoral ya había participado a la una
de la tarde hora local cuando ya habían
pasado siete horas de votación los
colegios electorales cierran a las 22
horas de túnez
afirma que este referendo llevará al
país a la autocracia por los poderes que
tendrá el presidente por su parte al
votar el mandatario cádiz iedt elogió el
mecanismo diciendo que será la base para
una nueva república el presidente
tunecino no ha explicado qué pasará si
los votantes rechazan el referéndum
veamos las reformas principales de esta
modificación a la constitución
el 26 de enero de 2014 tres años después
del inicio de la primavera árabe los
diputados tunecinos aprobaron una nueva
constitución el artículo primero era el
mismo que el de la constitución anterior
que data de
túnez es un estado libre independiente y
soberano su religión es el islam su
lengua el árabe y su sistema el
republicano el texto combina el laicismo
y el islam por primera vez en un país
árabe la constitución garantiza la
libertad de creencia y de conciencia y
el libre ejercicio de la religión la
sharia no se menciona como parte de la
ley sin embargo ocho años después el
presidente tunecino caixa yet propone un
proyecto muy diferente
su objetivo es dar al jefe de estado una
fuente de poder incontestable
permitiendo la inmunidad durante toda la
duración de su mandato la nueva
constitución también reduce
considerablemente el papel y el poder
del parlamento y pretende instaurar una
segunda cámara la asamblea nacional de
regiones creadas según el modelo de los
senados franceses y estadounidense uno
de los puntos más polémicos preocupa en
lugar del islam el artículo 5 del
proyecto presidencial afirma que túnez
forma parte de la umma islámica dentro
de un sistema democrático sólo el estado
deberá velar y garantizar los objetivos
del islam esto ha sido criticado por los
partidarios de la separación de la
religión y del estado
y terminamos en eeuu el incendio que
sigue amenazando al parque nacional
yosemite y sigue fuera de control según
las autoridades del condado de mariposa
donde fue declarado el estado de
emergencia las llamas se expandieron
durante la noche la conflagración se ha
agravado por la intensa ola de calor que
golpea al país y también por la
vegetación seca el incendio que comenzó
el viernes ya ha consumido más de 6.700
hectáreas en un call fire las causas de
las llamas siguen bajo investigación
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]